and uh you know i've jynx is a key word
here because back in august when the nfl
was
kind of subtly thumping its chest from
time to time about the success it was
having in keeping the coronavirus out of
32 team facilities i had a head coach
text me and say would somebody please
tell them to shut up because
number one you're jinxing us and number
two you're gonna make people complacent
if they think it's no big deal and after
three weeks of the regular season
we kind of thought it was no big deal
and for the past two weeks it's been the
biggest deal that the nfl has had to
contend with and i answer these emails
every day shireen why are you talking
about the chronovice why why are you
well because there are significant
issues as it relates to whether teams
can practice and play when games are
going to be played and it's driving the
discussion i'd rather not talk about it
i'm sure you'd rather not talk about it
but the circumstances are forcing us to
and guess what it's going to be the lead
storyline for the rest of the year i
mean we've had
multiple game changes now we're going to
have more we see that this is not going
away mike and and covet is here and
covet rules and it's about risk
mitigation once it's in the locker room
as you've pointed out how do you keep it
from spreading and it's going to get
into locker rooms and we've seen that
yet again today with yet another team in
the jets
yeah and that's what happened today not
long after we wrapped the program
earlier i caught wind that the jets had
a player who tested positive poked
around wanted to be responsible for a
change i was so tempted to go with it
because i trusted my source but i i
wanted to i wanted to confirm it and i
wanted to get more information and i
learned that it's a presumptive positive
could home out of an abundance of
caution got a retest of the player who
tested positive and because the jets are
in new jersey and they're not that far
from the lab that does the testing
they're expecting to hear something
sooner rather than later i just found
out they haven't heard anything yet and
here we are at 503 pm eastern but that's
one of the realities of this shireen how
quickly you find out the results of your
off-site pcr testing
is driven by literally how far they have
to drive
to take the samples to the lab some
teams get their pcr off-site test
results early evening some get them late
evening some get them middle of the
night some get them the next morning and
for something that is that important
especially when
we're monitoring the potential for an
outbreak you'd like to think there's a
better way but there isn't it all hinges
on how long it takes to get the samples
from point a to point b
yeah mike frable said the other day they
get their test at 4 30 a.m so he gets up
looks at the test are there positives no
positive and of course the way they've
gone there have been positives almost
every day we did we haven't had any and
maybe they'll get to open their facility
and maybe they'll get to play this week
uh they're on the right track but we've
seen this before when they had one day
with no positives and then boom the next
day they had positive so they've got to
have two straight days without positives
and everyone there is crossing their
fingers but again we won't know until 4
30 a.m whether anybody tested positive
today so they need to do these quicker
and i know
back when this first started mike you
wrote a story in march april somewhere
around there that they expected that by
august and again thumping their chest
expected by august that we would have
turn around tasks 15 minutes boom before
you go into the facility we're gonna
test you we're gonna know if you have
covid before you walk into the building
that obviously hasn't happened we have a
donut hole in the testing as well when
they weren't testing on what the day of
the game day before the game they
weren't testing we've had that donut
hole shine itself brightly this week and
so
it it hasn't gone exactly as the nfl
plan starting back in march and it's
going again it's going to be the main
storyline whether people like it or not
we don't like it but it's going to
dictate this season for the nfl and how
it goes and we're going to have more
games postponed guaranteed
the biggest doughnut hole is the
incubation period and that's something
that i'm not sure anybody's really
focused on until we got into the season
and recognized if someone has an
exposure one day they may not generate a
positive test for four or five days
[Music]
relates to the pandemic but one of them
is
the impression they were creating by the
extremely flexible roster rules and most
specifically shireen the rule that
allows up to 16 members of the practice
squad to be elevated to the active
roster
as late as 90 minutes before kickoff
which creates the impression that you
could find out on saturday a bunch of
guys
are
positive
and hey we got 16 practice squad players
we're going to bump up as many as we
need to and we're going to be good to go
if they find out on sunday if there's a
test that gets redone if there's an
on-site point-of-care test they actually
don't do the point-of-care test because
they're concerned about false positives
but it created the idea that you just
take one guy out and put another guy in
what we're learning is it's not as
simple as taking one guy out because
once you take the one guy out you got to
figure out who else may end up getting
this whether it's people who are in
close contact whether it's people who
were in close contact but it didn't show
up through the tracking device that was
one of the concerns last saturday night
with the saints four guys sitting around
michael burton the fullback who had a
false positive they weren't flagged by
the league's device
as to people who needed to be monitored
and tested even though they were close
enough that they would have gotten it so
that this is a disconnect
and
that's why
you know a lot of people are saying well
no big deal guys positive just kind of
kick him to the curb until he's ready to
come back and keep going that's not
happening that's why they sent everybody
home today from the jets facility that's
why the patriots have been home for a
few days that's why the titans aren't
back
once it's in
you don't know when the next domino has
fallen until days after the fact and
that chain can continue and i think it
took the titans example to get the
league to take a step back and say
holy crap this is a hell of a lot more
complicated than we thought
yeah it's not as simple as next man up
for sure and that that's what the nfl
motto has been for years hey next man up
hey we have an injury our quarterback's
out next man up next man up well this
isn't next man up and it's not as simple
as that the patriots haven't you
mentioned them they haven't practiced
all week now they are planning on
opening reopening their facility
tomorrow having practice at 10 30 a.m it
will be their only practice of the week
before they go play so here you go
and that's kind of how it's going to be
this is going to be almost like winging
it in the nfl for for much of this
season for a lot of teams maybe not all
teams go through this but we've seen
multiple teams now have to sort of wing
it and coaches are not as we know good
at winging it so they're going to have
to learn how to do that and learn learn
how to do it in an effective and
efficient way because a lot of this is
going to be virtual meetings you're not
going to get to practice off-site as
we've seen the titans do and are going
to pay a stiff punishment we think for
that and so um they're going to have to
make do with what they have and sort of
be impromptu and be flexible on on
everything this entire year
one thing and i'm going to go off script
here even though we've got several other
topics to get to in this opening segment
paul allen by the way vikings
play-by-play voice is going to join us
in about 10-15 minutes
the harbaugh rule is now in effect
and if a coach or anyone approaches an
official with the mask down and i assume
they mean coach because the the the the
players don't have a mask that they can
put on when they're on the field so this
is directed mainly at coaches who would
be giving an official an earful if you
pull your mask down if your face isn't
covered you're subject to a 15-yard
penalty or a suspension or fine or loss
of draft picks and that's a reaction of
the complaint that was made because john
harbaugh was in the face of an official
last monday night against the chiefs
and and this is another one of the
disconnects because when i asked the
league this week hey is there still a
rule that says you guys can't congregate
closer than six feet together after
games they said yeah that's still the
rule and then they sent me the cdc
information that says you got to be
within six feet of someone for 15
minutes to transmit the virus so okay
well
why are you sending me this why are you
citing this
if your rule is you can't do it and why
is your rule that you can't do it if the
cdc guidance says you have to be pressed
together for 15 minutes so there's all
these mixed messages everywhere we look
and this is another one the nfl in one
breath would say no pun intended that
you have to be in the same vicinity as
someone else for 15 minutes to transmit
the virus and then in the next breath
they say thou shalt not approach an
official with your mask uncover your
face uncovered so i
they it would just be nice
whether it's the nfl
or
society at large for us all to have
one set of rules
that we go by as to how this thing works
because it's all over the place and i i
i is that too much to ask shireen that
we just have one set of rules for this
thing
i i want one set of rules that would be
fantastic and then everyone would know
how to react you know people are still
sticking out their hands to shake their
hands i saw it if you watched hard
knocks and i know you didn't watch much
of it i don't think this year but i i
watched all of hard knocks and the first
thing i think it was the first episode
maybe the second when sean mcveigh is
going to cut a player he immediately
reaches out his hand and shakes hand and
i tweeted shot somebody tell sean
mcveigh to stop shaking hands and i know
it's natural and i know it's what we're
accustomed to doing but all those things
have gone away and they're probably
going to go away forever so i don't know
if it's a fist bump or elbow bump or
figure something else out and let's
let's have a rule that what we're gonna
do to uh greet each other and all those
other things would be nice to know
polite non would be great nod a salute
whatever the case may be
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports